ragazzi questa è la storia di come ho
conosciuto how i met your mother non è
certo una storia piena di esplosioni e
di incredibili avventure ma è un
qualcosa che mi piacerebbe condividere
con voi questo sono io
qualche secondo dopo aver visto il
finale di serie ma ne parleremo più
avanti
abbiamo tempo partiamo dal 2005 quando
ancora la mia vita era fatta di compiti
a casa e mattarelli sulle tempi perché
quei compiti non le facevo in quel
periodo su internet non si parlava
d'altro che di questo lost una serie che
ha catturato milioni di persone con i
suoi misteri i suoi personaggi e le sue
pause
dopo la prima stagione sulla rai la
gente scoprì che la seconda era già
iniziata in america
quindi grazie al miglior amico dell'uomo
google cerca un modo per alzare le vele
e pinatar e come dei cani non so gli
altri ma io finisco in un sito ai tempi
ancora sconosciuto italiansubs puntonet
come creano sottotitoli per telefilm
come ci sono anche quelli per la seconda
stagione di lost
ma cosa c'entra tutto ciò con aura met
your mother ci arriveremo tra le
iconcine dei sottotitoli spuntava spesso
questa immagine era una sitcom iniziata
da poco ma di cui tutti parlavano molto
bene ma non c'era tempo per ridere
dovevo di seguire un fumo nero e aprire
una botola che tra l'altro immaginatevi
per uno che consegue nostro sentire
spesso seguivi botole fumi neri che
calzi tele figura d'uomo
saltiamo avanti di tre anni stavo seduto
sul divano a fare zapping in tv tra un
talk show politico e pubblicità di
suonerie sotto gli occhi mi capita e
alla fine arriva mamma
guardo gli attori e li riconosco sono
quelli delle immaginette dai guardiamolo
dieci minuti dopo tornò a guardare
virgole la sua suoneria strappa [ __ ]
quella sitcom non mi era piaciuta non
faceva ridere
dunque perché la gente del web ne
parlava bene magari
io stupido voglio dire ho giudicato una
serie dopo solo ai sette puntate non
capendo un cazzo quindi tutto è
possibile
diamole un'altra chance in lingua
originale però alla fine sono su quel
sito apposta bordo la prima mi piace mi
dico va bene guardo un altro paio
due giorni dopo finiscono la prima
stagione è che e da allora non ho mai
più smesso di guardarlo e difficile dire
cosa vi piaccia in particolare sarà la
presenza di una trama che la differenzia
da tutte le altre sit com per esempio io
adoro i robinson e la vita secondo jim
ma nonostante anche loro siano sitcom
sono imparagonabili quasi come sia a met
your mother fosse di un'altra categoria
i personaggi sono fin da subito
riconoscibili e molto carismatici
marshall e lily la coppia d'annata del
gruppo fidanzati da una vita la prova
vivente che gli opposti si attraggono
bar nei parte come spalla comica ma man
mano si trasforma in una persona vera
tra gli attori più bravi degli ultimi
anni e secondo me provin
è l'ultima arrivata del gruppo una
giornalista canadese con le palle e di
una bellezza rara e dulcis in fundo ed
il nostro protagonista un architetto
sognatore alla perenne ricerca
dell'anima gemella
ed è il fulcro su cui gira l'intera
storia all'apparenza era un innocente
telefilm comico ma più andavo avanti e
più capivo che c'era molto di più di
quel che sembrava vengono toccati
argomenti come destino solitudine vita e
morte
ma cosa succede uno è proprio il rider e
ne esce pieno di sentimenti incredibili
cazzo per una sit com
la struttura è uguale a quella di altri
colleghi la coppia fissa alla spalla e
la coppia che si lascia si molla si
lascia simo vita sia la cd monte del
robin alla fine sono come rosse recen
jay elliot leonard e penny ryan e marisa
sherlock e watson ma come dicevo prima è
la trama far diventare how i met your
mother una perla questa costante ricerca
del vero amore decidere di credere nel
destino o in un insieme di coincidenze
che ti hanno portato dove sei ora e
potrei stare delle ore a spiegarvi la
profondità di alcune puntate di alcune
serie ma siamo qui per parlare di
un'altra cosa
e alla fine arriva il finale devo dire
che
esserci rimasto male è riduttivo oh
merda che cacciano combinatori non ne ho
idea
hanno praticamente disintegrato tutto
quello che in nove anni si è visto dai
personaggi della storto e tutto faceva
una lista primo il matrimonio l'ultima
stagione ha avuto impostarla con il
matrimonio tra marmi e robbie è per
contro alcune puntate fossero magari un
po più lente di altre perché essendo
tutto in dieta tv weekend e o perché
qualche puntata sarebbe stata un po
tirata per le lunghe
ma in fin dei conti guardandola
nell'insieme tralasciando ultima puntata
da una stagione non è neanche neanche
così tanto male da questo in una ventina
di puntate per dirci che marmi aveva
ripensamenti ma poi ci ripensa agli
pensamenti quindi vuole stare con robbie
robin non sa se stare come un no ma alla
fine ci sta e tutta questa serie norme
per farli stare insieme e cosa succede
nei primi tre minuti della puntata
abbiamo divorziato cazzo e anche lì di
molta gente dice che il mio problema è
che non ho capito che di voci potrebbe
succedere sì ma come non è che dopo
venti puntate per farli mettere
deve sposarli dopo cinque minuti di
puntata dell'ultima puntata di file che
ha tra l'altro mentre andavo a prendere
il parà abbiamo divorziato dalla moglie
e il problema principali tutta statura e
che affrontano nelle durante le stagioni
affrontano i problemi della vita in modo
molto ampio e facendo di trasformare i
personaggi e con il nuovo qui c'era la
lista della spesa o coperto con zucchero
comprato fare ho comprato il salame
abbiamo divorziato e che è senza un po
di sviluppo di questa cosa qua dimmi
perché è come quando facevo il leader e
magari qualche flash non lo so prendi
dell'utile è inutile tutta l'ultima
stagione esempio nel caso telefilm
ambientato nel calcio 24 puntate per
allenarli alla partita della fina
all'incredibile della coppa di super
cazzi della vita e nell'ultima puntata
di la martina non c'è carelli prossima
stagione fatico a capire il senso di
questa cosa ma comunque seconda cosa
distaccato imputata palme anche nove
anni di evoluzione del personaggio lo
fai sposare con robbie perché anche il
il soldatino di blatche al cazzo di
cuore e si innamora per il soldatino di
latta non era ciondoli porta e poi lo
fai tornare i playboy che la prima è il
veto non è quello il problema è il
problema è che la fanno ritornare in una
frazione di secondo
buttando tutte le nuove stagioni prima
robin sei tutta la mia vita solo
cambiato per te ho capito di essere vero
uomo per te basta non so più voglia ho
voglia di andare a fare le gnocche
e come se non bastasse fa un figlio con
un personaggio che non si è mai vista
di cui non si sa neanche il nome vado a
farmi le squinzie ha tra l'altro una
delle scritte che mi sono fatto senza
protezione rimaste incinte sono
diventato papà comune temi stronzi e la
generici però non puoi non essersi
commosso per bene non mi sono commosso
fermarmi perché una cosa talmente
stupida come l'hanno fatta avrebbero
potuto farlo sviluppare il personaggio
nella ss la fortunata stagione
ovviamente perché si comincia con tanta
non è che c'è tanto tempo per sviluppare
personaggi per un anno fatto comunque
quindi applauso al neo papà che ha una
figlia con una sgallettata qualsiasi per
sbaglio commovente v terzo punto la
morte della madre anche di tutta la
sorpresa perché la madre è morta
l'opera a parte che si era un po intuito
che sarebbe morta con alcuni discorsi e
quella è una cosa molto bene che vi
avessero fatto intuire ma dio santo la
con quelle probabilmente tra le cose
peggiori la morte della madre stessa
cosa di prima come che hanno sbagliato
totalmente allora mi devi prendere
memorizza e salame formaggio prosciutto
cotto e non fatelo sbagliare tanto
spesso che quello lyman rapino e
trenitalia ha tra l'altro ragione la
lista dando poi buttano lì la madre
muore
arrivederci la scena dove muore la madre
dura sarà tre secondi vedi e quando
posta madre si ammalò fine non si sa
perché non si sa per cosa non hanno
fatto l'hanno fatto vedere prima un po
come si sono conosciuti come si sono
sposati figli eccetera eccetera ma manca
l'incontro quello bello che tutti si
aspettavano è proprio la madre che poi
magari muore saetti da quella forza
emotiva che ci sono stati in tutte le
altre cazzo di puntate tipo quando era
morto il padre di marshall che hanno
passato praticamente cinque puntate a
fanno recuperare dalla morte e siccome
la serie per quanto che se ne dica che
non la voce non è basato sulla madre
ma è come ha conosciuto la madre poi
magari come l'ha persa
ma siccome la serie come l'ha conosciuta
e poi mondo premesso una cosa importante
la morte della madre e nonna storia
pagina sfoglia pagine in un trafiletto
sotto 6 scritto ps al portatore della
madre muore ma vabbè tanto non è
importante tormento in un asterisco qua
sotto e poi dulcis in fundo tether ob
ragazzi questa è la storia di come ho
conosciuto vostra madre
no non è vero babbo questa storia di
come ti si chiamato più volte robin e
senza telefonare al giorno dopo a mente
ragione dopo a farlo di nuovo
anche lì malapena mi è piaciuto perché è
tornato corrono ci sta il problema è
sempre il cop e l'hanno fatto mi sia
gruppo stata sulle palle la cosa del
torno con robbie non puoi farlo gli
dicono gli amici 9 luglio tornare con
robbie e chissà di euro e quello la
scelta se ti piacciono però non posso
capirla quello che non posso concepire e
quando in questa [ __ ] post non ha
ragione che praticamente da cancellare
dalla memoria grazie all'ultima puntata
tu fai una puntata dove lasci andare
robbie la puntata quella anche un po
strana dove robin diventa un palloncino
e va via in un modo tutto tipo che cazzo
sta succedendo perché era collegata al
palloncino che tu hai lasciato andare
via e quindi lei diventa il palloncino
che tu avevi lasciato andare via
e questo vuol dire che basta media ma è
più dopo una puntata del genere dove tu
dici finalmente campioni del mondo non
si toccano più ge d'italia picerebbe e
non un po logico mio babbo vai a toccare
per l'ultima volta i genitali una volta
e per sempre a zia o b e tutto questo
per me cosa vuol dire che tutti i
discorsi sul destino sul trovare l'anima
gemella sull'amore infinito non vogliono
dire un cazzo e ogni
che li vedrò a 1 met your mother e ci
saranno quei discorsi sul trovare la
madre la madre che la perfezione su come
l'ha incontrata si tutta la storia che
si collega perfettamente per andare alla
la madre e poi la madre viene cancellato
inglesi pochi lui ritorna con robbie mi
dispiace ma vi verrà da vomitare i
grandi con attimi verranno e dovrò
correre baioni povere ci sarà una cosa
dicembre e quindi l'ultima puntata non
solo è una merda come l'ultima puntata
ma ha rovinato l'intera stagione
vabbè ci sono anche conti su per un
attimo
io topi detto anche l'allegria e sono
ancora tutt'ora incazzato per un finale
che ha rovinato
non solo il finale ma secondo me
l'intera serie però molta gente mi
chiede che è piaciuto il finale l'ho
detto no guarda ti spiego perchè non mi
è piaciuto loro molta moltissima gente
mi dice almeno la metà
mi dice no guarda a me è piaciuto e io
gli chiedo perfetto dimmi perché e le
loro motivazioni
sono comunque molto valide e quindi ho
iniziato a capire che questo finale è
paragonabile al anatra coniglio
guardate questa immagine è la famosa
immagine di un disegno che può essere
visto sia come anatra sia come coniglio
e finché non decidi cos'è entrambi e
della stessa identica cosa per
l'episodio finale
alcuni l'hanno visto come anatra altri
l'hanno visto come coniglio perché
esattamente come nell'immagine nessuno
dei due ha ragione ma nessuno dei due ha
torto
quella puntata è sia un anatra che un
coniglio ed è sempre molto divertenti
discutere con la gente che riesce ad
avere un dialogo e riuscire a capire
quali sono i punti di forza e quali sono
i punti a sfavore di questo episodio
wow internet finalmente si è riusciti a
non mandare merda qualcosa scelte che
dialoga pacificamente parlando di
opinioni personaggio e quindi siamo qui
non ho idea se voi abbiate mai visto la
met your mother se avete intenzione di
farlo io vi consiglio
fatelo e poi magari fra qualche anno
finite a cercare questo video per dire
amy anatra coniglio
[Musica]